I was thinking over the weekend how
things have really changed in the last
year in American politics in so many
ways not only the perception of the
United States around the world and not
only sort of role of the u.s. in really
important discussions about the climate
and about authoritarianism and fresh
press freedoms and free press and so
many other areas but also how much
things have changed in terms of the
President of the United States and what
I mean by that is that a year ago we had
the Trump Russia investigation in this
sort of earlier phase we had a sort of
obviously bogus House Intelligence
Committee investigation which we knew
was never going to find anything it was
after all led by Donald Trump's friend
Devin Nunez who was running to the White
House to keep Trump apprised of what it
was that that committee was doing now as
we are almost at the end of 2018 we're
learning that almost every aspect of the
president's life before being candid at
Trump during the campaign during the
presidency every aspect of Donald
Trump's life may contain criminality and
it is the presidency which has exposed
that and now he and his family and his
inner circle are all under investigation
for possible criminality remember that
before being handed at Trump we now have
learned that Donald Trump may have been
involved in the money laundering of
Russian and Saudi money through real
estate deals particularly in Manhattan
New York Donald Trump was employing
undocumented immigrants both by proxy
through the undocumented immigrants
employed by contractors that Donald
Trump worked with and also even directly
we've now learned that multiple
undocumented immigrants were working at
Donald Trump's New Jersey Golf Club at
minimum that we know of
specifically shady banking deals with
Deutsche Bank under very strange
circumstances that Robert Muller is
looking into those are examples of
possible criminality by Trump before he
even decided to run for president of the
United States then we get to the
campaign where there is a whole slew of
additional possible criminality
illegal coordination with Russia
receiving things of value from
country's for the purposes of winning an
election in his case the 2016
presidential election directing
felonious payoffs via his attorney
Michael Cohen two mistresses possibly in
conjunction with Ami the parent company
of the National Enquirer and many others
and then we also get to phase three
which is during the presidency and even
transitioning in the to the presidency
potential crimes now around fraud
regarding Donald Trump's inauguration
and donations that were received for it
that is now being investigated of course
we've been talking for months now
obstruction of justice of the Trump
Russia probe firing all sorts of people
including James Comey witness tampering
both implicitly and explicitly via
private and public means trying to
influence the testimony of individuals
within the context of that investigation
emoluments violations dignitaries from
around the world choosing to stay at
Donald Trump's hotel in Washington DC to
ingratiate themselves with him of course
funneling money directly to his personal
pocket since that is one of his
businesses and you know what Pat it's
not even just Trump so we've got
possible Trump criminality before during
and after he was candidate Trump we also
now have Trump's be a family
increasingly pulled into this Donald
Trump jr. expecting an indictment
considering heading to Canada so that
he's gone when the news breaks his
business associates others from the
Trump Organization his advisors and
attorneys cabinet members are dropping
like flies interior secretary Ryan's
Enki is bailing under a huge black cloud
of misuse of taxpayer money as usual ten
cabinet secretaries in total have now
left more than Obama and Bush and
Clinton lost in two years sixty percent
of trumps aides have left in the first
two years outrageous turnover rate more
than the last five presidents by far so
this is now pat every aspect of Donald
Trump's life even now possible
criminality on the behalf of Donald from
Father
has come to light not that that would be
prosecutable the guy died long ago this
is not the best decision for Trump has
it been to become president of the
United States not a good decision at all
and I don't know if they would take it
back if he could and many of these
possible crimes we knew about before he
was even elected president that's why we
thought there was something Shady with
the fact that he wouldn't release his
tax returns we knew there was some
sketchy ties between him and the Saudi
Arabians or him and the Russians and you
can't also forget the serial sexual
assault and harassment of women many of
those cases I'm sure border on
criminality so this was all kind of
baked in and the American public knew
about this before voting for him that's
why I'm kind of concerned that if
something major comes out that it won't
change things because this has already
baked into the cake and you have now
legal experts even one on Fox News
saying that Donald Trump is effectively
an unindicted co-conspirator in at least
the crimes of Michael Cohen because he
directed Michael Cohen to commit those
felonies the only element of this that's
out of place is that the devoted
trumpets and the devoted right-wing
media pretend that this is not happening
if we can say anything positive about
Donald Trump it's that very few people
of his profile would actually survive
this onslaught he shouldn't be able to
survive this given the rampant
criminality that's been exposed but he
might because of a combination of the
power of the Oval Office and incumbency
and the fact that he still has committed
ideological hardcore right-wing media
allies that are pretending that nothing
is going on because this should have
destroyed him a long time ago and it
still might we don't know just yet and
part of it of course is that there are
two justice systems I've been talking
about this for years we have adjust the
system for the wealthy and the powerful
and then adjust the system for everybody
else
lastly beyond all of this just as a
final coda we haven't even gotten into
the litany of state-level charges that
state attorneys general are going to be
looking into we've heard that Maryland
in Washington DC are going to look into
emoluments violations by Trump at the
state level not pardonable new
defamation
suit against Trump is back from summer
servos that former apprentice contestant
that is now happening New York state
level investigation into Trump using his
charity like a personal slush fund truly
stunning and the most stunning thing in
the end the most damaging thing in the
end in terms of what it says about the
American justice system will be if
Donald Trump is able to get out
unscathed and he may well and that would
be the real tragedy here